okay.
Time for audience questions for the week.
First question.
Hey David, why are people calling what Donald
Trump did a quid pro quo instead of just calling
it bribery or extortion?
Very good question.
And something I've been talking about
for a while.
The the media cycles are basically referring
to it as a quid pro quo.
And what I realized was the problem was that
there was a lot of debate over whether it
was a quid pro quo without people knowing
what quid pro quo means, which of course I
think the, the gist of the Latin is a, you
scratch my back, I'll scratch yours.
Something for something else, something in
exchange for something else.
This for that.
It is not in a literal Latin translation,
although I think that it's generally a accurate
when in reality if you don't actually understand
what that means, you might not understand
that.
We're basically talking about actions by Donald
Trump that would be bribery or or extortion.
So let's look at the definitions here.
Quid pro quo defined in English would be a
favor or advantage granted or expected in
return for something.
So it does describe what took place with,
we need you to do us a favor.
The military aid smear investigations of Joe
Biden by Ukraine and the Ukrainian president
Zelenskyi quid pro quo is not an inaccurate
term, but a lot of people don't understand
it and it's probably not a strong enough term
bribery.
On the other hand, the giving or offering
of a bribe, which is a sum of money or other
inducement offered given, offered or given
to bribe someone, uh, seems to me a much more
precise and actually much more indicative
of the true sort of nature, scope and severity
of what has taken place to bribe is to persuade
someone to act in one's favor.
For example, by smearing Joe Biden typically
illegally or at least dishonestly or immorally,
you could argue via a gift of money or other
inducement.
It is literally what is believed, what is
alleged to have taken place between Trump
and the Ukrainian president.
There was the attempt by the Trump administration,
including on the July 25 phone call, but also
beyond it.
What led up to it as we know in other conversations,
the idea was let's persuade Ukraine to publicly
announce an investigation of Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden for the purposes of hurting Joe
Biden's chances in 2020 to help Donald Trump
in exchange for a gift of money or inducement.
In this case it was military aid money for
the country.
Now what's interesting about that is the attempt
to persuade on that basis is the bribery regardless
of whether the bribe is accepted or ever actually
paid, and that is another reason why we really
should be calling it bribery instead of quid
pro quo.
Quid pro quo accurately or inaccurately is
often interpreted as one thing for the other
and the things are exchanged.
When you look at the different definition
of bribery and what a bribe is, the language
makes it much more clear that the attempt,
the persuasion attempt, the inducement, regardless
of whether it's accepted still counts as a,
as a bribe, as an attempted bribe, as bribery,
and that's really important.
And then we also get to extortion.
Now the definition of extortion is the practice
of obtaining something, especially money through
force or threats.
So you can say that when you consider the
geopolitical imbalance of power between the
United States and Ukraine, you can reasonably
make the case that when a white house, when
the Trump white house tries to obtain smears
on Joe Biden from Ukraine, they are using
force and threats.
Is it physical force?
No, Trump is not saying he's going to show
up and punch president Zelenskyi.
It's not that.
But when you consider the power dynamic, we
could certainly argue that it is the use of
force to obtain something from Ukraine.
And that in that sense it also qualifies as
extortion.
So these are certainly more commonly known
and understood terms.
I believe that they more precisely describe
what it is that took place.
So I think that we can't not use the term
quid pro quo at all because it's still in
the conversation, but I'm going to make an
effort to say, um, what is being described
as a quid pro quo.
It's actually a bribery and even extortion.
I think I'm going to start making that point
every time and I appreciate you bringing it
up to me